laurent slovaque préposé aux soins des
animaux à la fondation phone
on est à la fondation faune qui est
située à carignan sur la rive sud de
montréal depuis 1981 petit créé par la
fondatrice gloria gros avec l'aide de
son mari dr allen un vétérinaire un
sanctuaire donc qui est ni un sou ni
ouvert au public c'est vraiment un
endroit de vie tranquille pour les
chimpanzés pour leur permettre de
d'avoir une belle fin de vie il ya aucun
argent du gouvernement qui vient à la
fondation c'est vraiment des dons privés
[Musique]
les douches un pas et qu'on était des
chimpanzés de laboratoire de recherche
ils ont été utilisés dans des
expérimentations biomédicale on en a eu
quelques-uns qui venaient d'eux ou ainsi
que deux d'université dans l'état de
washington aux etats unis
on se rend compte la ressemblance qui
entre les chimpanzés et les humains
c'est pratiquement de se dire qu'on
utilise un humain en laboratoire pour
leur faire des tests il enfermé dans des
tout-petits cage au fil du temps s'est
rendu compte que c'est inhumain
puis aujourd'hui ça se fait plus dans
les laboratoires de recherche
j'ai fait un bac en psychoéducation donc
à la fin de mon bac j'avais besoin
quelque chose doit changer un petit peu
les esprits et puis j'ai commencé à
l'entretien paysager à la fondation
phone et puis il ya eu une opportunité
pour moi travailler avec les chimpanzés
donc ça a changé ma vie
la vie en captivité pour un chimpanzé
apporte beaucoup de troubles
psychologiques
il y en a plusieurs qui souffre de
stress post traumatique autant pour la
vie en laboratoire que la vie en joue
malheureusement ils n'ont pas toutes les
habiletés requises pour survivre par eux
mêmes en nature lorsqu'ils sont nés en
captivité
c'est sûr qu'on voit l'évolution fait
les années ça c'est toujours
encourageant pour nous ça veut dire que
ça va bien ils sentent beaucoup mieux
une fois qu'ils sont arrivés ici c'est
nos amis finalement c'est nos collègues
de travail c'est pour eux qu'on se
déplace à tous les jours pour la plupart
c'est vraiment des chimpanzés qui sont
capables de communiquer ou niveau mais
verbal fait du temps on les connaît on
va savoir quel geste veut dire quoi
mais il ya aussi deux chimpanzés ici à
la fondation qui ont appris le langage
des signes
tu as tout à prier jusqu'à 250 mo en
langage des signes
il boit elle est capable de nous
exprimer ses émotions dire directement
ce qu'elle voudrait pour manger pour
boire donc une communication vraiment
dire à qui ce fait avec elle le côté
difficile
si je peux dire moralement peut être
vraiment au fil du temps de les voir de
voir nos amis nos compagnons restés dans
les cages pour le restant de leurs jours
les accompagner aussi vers la mort et
tout un côté plutôt soins palliatifs
aujourd'hui en 2018 et d'autres façons
de faire finalement que d'utiliser les
animaux en laboratoire ce serait mon
rêve ultime
[Musique]